what does algebra it's simple it's all
about puzzles here's one for you this
plus two equals five we just have to
find the number in this box which number
when added to two gives us five simple
it's three we can say that three plus
two equals five this thing we see here
contains only numbers this puzzle can
also be asked in a different way we can
say that X plus two equals five find X
we just used a letter in place of the
box these letters are also called as
variables sometimes also referred to as
the unknown since its values is not
known to us this is algebra it deals
with variables and unknowns and we are
expected to find their value but why use
variables
why not boxes like these let's assume
there are three unknown numbers using
shapes we can write it as a square plus
a slant square plus an empty circle plus
four equals seven you have to think of
different shapes using variables we can
write it as X plus y plus Z plus four
equals seven
this was a little more convenient as
compared to the previous case but what's
the real advantage of using variables
read the short story and a question that
follows your friend had a few chocolates
with him a bully came across
took away five of his chocolates and
then he had just seven chocolates
remaining with him how many chocolates
did he have before the bully came to him
this question has 40 words let's see if
it can shorten the question a bit assume
your friend had ex-jock a--let's with
him the bully took away five of his
chocolates so we subtract five from X
and after all this your friend was left
with seven chocolates this entire thing
will then equal seven now all we have to
do is find X this entire question of 40
words can be written like this
so yes algebra makes life simple
[Music]